ben à la semaine prochaine bientôt 14
cathy est agent d'entretien
toutes les semaines elle vient faire
deux heures de ménage chez ceux
particuliers il y a deux ans cette mère
de trois enfants est tombé malade elle a
perdu la moitié de ses employeurs et de
son salaire aujourd'hui elle travaille
18 heures par semaine et gagne 600 euros
par mois vous préparer à des t bonds
restantes pas de dire soir pour le midi
c'est à lui de cuisiner comme ça je peux
manger directement juste à réchauffer au
micro ondes ce midi elle mange mais la
plupart du temps elles sautent des repas
lundi midi je mange pas mais je mange
plus fort pour faire des économies
d'après ses calculs
elles dépensent entre 70 et 100 euros de
courses par semaine pour la famille
tiennent mettons j'achète que des pâtes
et que je marion tout vu entre pathé
frites ça va revenir moins cher si je
veux faire un mettons un de meilleur
report par exemple
un petit peu de saumon ou des trucs
comme ça amène des idées n'est pas de
faire des tos ça coûtera plus cher
difficile pour cathy de manger équilibré
difficile aussi de payer le reste des
charges peut aider à la fin du mois elle
a du mal à joindre les deux bouts
elle est menacée d'expulsion de son
logement tu payes et cela selon les
clients que j'ai sa part de 8 euros 5 à
10 euros
quand on compte les factures le gaz et
l'électricité l'eau le loyer la
nourriture la coaching pour les enfants
parce qu'il faut payer ça aussi les
abonnements téléphoniques et tout ce qui
s'ensuit
voilà c'est les 600 euros sont partis en
fumée
vos propres enfants qui vous dit alors
tu es notre mère on a rien dans notre
assiette pourquoi on a pu pourquoi tu
fais des toujours des pâtes en tant que
maman c'est pas facile à vivre
déjà menacée d'expulsion il ya dix ans
elle s'était tournée vers l'association
atd quart monde
depuis elle est devenue militante sont
plus à ma place je fais des choses et le
grec le fait de sentir faire quelque
chose pour soi même et pour les autres
mais c'est ce que je voulais redonner
confiance à des personnes en situation
d'extrême précarité
c'est l'un des objectifs de
l'association atd quart monde lamy une
personne pauvre entre guillemets bien
c'est une personne qu'on considère comme
rien du tout vous comprenez et dont on
ne reconnaît pas les valeurs et le
l'énergie la ténacité qui a pour se
lever le matin alors que alors que c'est
la merde on joue bien mais franchement
qu'est dès que voilà quoi je veux dire
moi j'ai des situations que certaines
personnes vivent je ne résisterai pas
sortir de la pauvreté
c'est le rêve de cathy la jeune lilloise
ne demandent qu'à travailler plus mais
manque d'accompagnement pour revenir à
temps plein dans le marché du travail